Have you ever, you know, thrown
your full energy behind a
brilliant idea?
Or maybe seen a social movement
just ignite with incredible
passion?
Oh yeah.
Or even just watched a new
initiative launch big fanfare
everything, only for it to
eventually, well, kind of lose
its spark.
Happens all the time.
Or just struggles, right, to
create that lasting, deep change
everyone was hoping for.
And it's so tempting, isn't it,
to point fingers at the obvious
opposition?
Loud critics?
Yes.
Exactly.
The ACT resistors, the people
openly fighting it.
But what if the biggest barrier
isn't really that direct
confrontation?
What if it's something, I don't
know, way more subtle, quiet,
but maybe even more powerful?
That's a really interesting
angle.
Welcome to the deep dive.
Today we're going to unpack this
fascinating and I think often
overlooked concept that might
just be that silent force.
It's called cultural inertia and
it might be the single biggest
barrier to progress.
We're grounding our discussion
today in a really compelling
piece from Substack by Chris
Abraham titled Fighting American
Culture Inertia.
Now, that article frames the
challenge specifically around
creating a more anti racist
America, which is obviously
huge.
But the insights, I think they
resonate much wider than just
that one context.
Absolutely.
The principles seem pretty
universal.
So our mission today is
basically to dig into this idea,
pull out the key insights, maybe
uncover some surprising truths
about how societies actually
change, or maybe more
accurately, how they resist
changing.
Yeah, that resistance is key.
And we want to offer you a
shortcut to understanding this
challenge because it's often
misidentified, isn't it?
We're diving into why these big
societal shifts are just so
incredibly difficult, even when
you know a lot of people might
theoretically agree with the
goals.
Even when there's a parent
consensus.
Right.
It's about more than fighting
vocal opponents.
It's about understanding and,
well, ultimately figuring out
how to move this whole system
that just kind of prefers to
stay put.
Likes it's equilibrium.
Exactly.
So let's jump in.
Maybe we should start with the
science.
Where does this idea even come
from?
Yeah, that's a great starting
point.
The author does a really nice
job connecting the societal
thing back to, well, basic
physics.
Inertia.
Right from science class.
Exactly.
In physics, inertia is just that
property of any object, any
physical thing that makes it
resist changes to how it's
moving or not moving.
OK, if something still, it wants
to stay still.
If it's moving and wants to keep
moving, same speed, same
direction, unless some outside
force acts on it.
Like that classic example, the
big boulder sitting on a flat
field.
Perfect example.
It's not going to just decide to
start rolling, is it?
It stays there until, I don't
know, something massive pushes
it or there's an earthquake
maybe.
Right.
Some significant external forces
needed.
Or think about a car on cruise
control on a flat highway.
You turn off the engine.
It doesn't just instantly stop,
it keeps rolling for a bit.
It resists that change, that
slowing down until friction, air
resistance, you know, the brakes
finally overcome its momentum.
It's like this inherent
stubbornness built into matter
itself.
Precisely.
And the beauty of using this
physics analogy is it highlights
that this resistance isn't
something you can just wish away
or ignore.
It's fundamental.
It's not temporary.
No.
It's a core property, and that
intrinsic resistance to change
is what makes inertia so
powerful and often so
frustrating if you're the one
trying to initiate the change.
It applies to everything, Atoms,
galaxies, the whole lot.
OK, so that makes sense for
physical objects, but how do we
take that concept and apply it
to something as well squishy and
abstract as culture or a whole
society?
How can that have weight or
resistance?
Yeah, and that's the leap the
source makes, and I think it
makes it quite effectively.
It argues that societies, just
like physical objects,
inherently prefer to stay as
they are.
They have their own kind of
inertia.
Societal inertia.
Exactly.
They resist change unless just
like that boulder or that car.
Enough energy and will unpack
what energy means in this
context, but enough energy is
consistently applied to nudge
them or push them in a new
direction.
So it's not just a metaphor that
the piece is saying.
This is like a fundamental
dynamic.
That's the argument, yes.
It's presented as a core
principle of how societies
operate.
And this is where the real
challenge, the subtlety of
cultural inertia, really hits
you.
How so?
Because it's not usually a loud,
angry opposition that you can
point to and say there's the
problem.
The source describes it as a
quiet, slow and hard to notice.
OK, quiet, slow, hard to notice,
not like a protest.
Right.
It's more like this pervasive
atmosphere, a kind of deep
seated stillness that keeps old
patterns alive.
Think about how often a new law
gets passed, maybe something
really progressive about
equality or fairness.
Yeah.
Big headlines, Policy changes.
Right on paper, the rules have
changed overnight sometimes.
But the actual everyday stuff,
the habits, the ingrained
attitudes, the unspoken
assumptions that law is trying
to change.
It's way longer.
Way longer because people just
naturally tend to cling to
routines.
Why?
Well, because it's just easier.
Easier than changing.
Yeah, even if those same people
say, Oh yeah, I agree with that
new law, that's a good idea.
There's a cognitive load, right?
Learning new ways, adapting,
challenging your own biases.
It takes effort.
It's simply less work to keep
doing what you've always done.
So the legal framework might
shift, like the operating system
gets an update saying do X now,
but the underlying cultural apps
are still running the old code
whispering yeah, but it's just
easier to keep doing.
Y, that's a great way to put it.
And Y continues often kind of
under the radar, not necessarily
out of defiance, maybe just
apathy or comfortable habit.
Wow, the source really drives
this point home, doesn't it?
It says culture has weight.
That weight is inertia.
That's a really powerful image,
picturing the sheer mass of all
the established norms, the
shared beliefs, collective
memories, habits, all of it
making up the society.
It's not just individuals, it's
this system with its own
gravity.
It really is, yeah.
And looking at it that way helps
explain why progress, even after
you get those landmark legal
wins or political victories, can
feel so frustratingly slow, like
you're pushing that boulder
uphill, Sisyphus style, Right?
People might intellectually
agree, they might not along say
the right things in a survey.
But the actual friction of
changing their daily lives,
their workplaces, family
dynamics, community
interactions, it's often just
too much effort without some
kind of sustained push or
incentive.
Which explains why old patterns
seem to just creep back in, or
they stick around in slightly
different forms, maybe less
obvious ones.
Exactly.
Even after big, well-intentioned
efforts for change, that
immense, subtle weight of
culture is constantly, quietly
trying to pull things back to
where they were, back to the
path of least resistance.
Like trying to turn a giant
super tanker, you can't just
yank the wheel hard left and
expect it to turn on a dime.
No, you need that persistent,
deliberate force applied over a
long, long time.
OK, that's a really profound
point and it leads right into
what the source calls the
misunderstood opponent.
Because usually when we talk
about big societal changes like
the example used in the piece
creating a more anti racist
America, our go to assumption,
or at least what the media often
focuses on, is that the main
enemy is open hatred.
Right, the explicit stuff.
Yeah, we focus our energy, our
attention on the really visible
antagonists, visible racists,
white supremacists, hate groups.
They're obvious, tangible.
They make headlines, they
provoke outrage.
They feel like the target.
And this is where the source
offers this frankly quite
cerbering reframing.
It argues that these visible
loud forces while incredibly
harmful and needing to be
addressed.
Of course they are.
Actually, numerically speaking,
small forces in the big picture,
they don't represent the bulk of
society.
The larger challenge, the
article contends, is the vast
weight of a society that does
not want to move.
That is the core of cultural
inertia in action.
It's not the active, shouting
opposition that's the biggest
hurdle.
It's the quiet, passive, maybe
even unconscious resistance of
the vast majority.
It's almost like a geological
force, slow but immensely
powerful.
OK, so if we're not primarily
fighting, you know, the people
waving hateful signs, who are we
actually dealing with this
inertial majority?
What do they look like?
The source paints a really clear
picture, and it's almost, well,
disarmingly normal.
These are not extremists.
They're not people deeply
invested in the culture wars on
either side.
They're activists.
No.
Their lives, the source points
out, revolve around things most
people can relate to.
Their jobs, their families,
their hobbies, and maybe most
importantly, a deep, almost
instinctive desire to avoid
conflict and maintain stability.
The quiet middle.
Pretty much the vast, quiet
middle.
And when you look at their
behaviors, it becomes even
clearer why traditional protest
tactics or, you know,
confrontational approaches often
don't move them well, the piece
says they accept small changes
they cannot avoid.
Maybe a new HR policy at work or
a new street sign.
But crucially, they rarely lead
them.
They follow, They don't
initiate.
And this is a point activists
often miss, according to the
source.
They are not moved by slogans or
threats.
A trending hashtag or an angry
article isn't going to suddenly
change their mind.
And shaming doesn't work either.
No, the source is very clear.
They do not respond to shame.
If anything, trying to shame
them often backfires.
It makes them dig in.
Creates resentment, not
conversion.
Their number one priority,
overwhelmingly, is just
stability.
They just want things to stay.
Calm.
They hold still.
They're not necessarily opposing
progress out of malice, they
just prefer not to be disrupted.
It's like a basic human
instinct, almost like conserving
energy.
Stick to the familiar path, it's
easier.
That statistic the source uses
is really jarring though.
If 70 to 90% of the population
is like this, I mean that
changes everything, doesn't it?
It completely reframes the task.
Yeah, it means societal change
isn't about defeating a small
group of last opponents.
That feels like a clear fight.
Good versus evil, maybe?
Right identifiable sides.
But if you're dealing with this
vast quiet majority, it becomes
a much more amorphous long term
challenge.
So the strategy has to be
totally different.
Exactly.
The implication is huge.
The challenge shifts from
defeating loud opponents or just
one small part of the picture
here, to finding energy to move
the quiet majority that resists
movement.
That means the tactics, the way
you communicate, the whole
approach has to be different.
If you're just shouting at or
trying to shame 80% of people
who just want to get on with
their lives and feel overwhelmed
already, it's not going to work.
You're likely to fail, and you
might even harden their
resistance, make them less open
next time.
It because about persuasion,
maybe invitation rather than
force or imposition.
And that shift in understanding
helps explain why so many
movements, even with great
intentions and initial energy,
seem to just stall out or fade
away.
This is where the piece gets
really interesting, I think.
It argues that movements often
profoundly underestimate this
silent, pervasive force, this
inertia.
I think the idea is so good
it'll just catch on by itself.
Exactly.
They mistakenly believe that
change, once you get it started
with a big splash or a law
passed, will sort of spread on
its own, like it has its own
momentum just because it's right
or logical.
But the source says.
Flat out it does not.
Couch, that's a tough truth.
It is, but it's vital.
If we want to get beyond these
cycles of big hope followed by
disillusionment, we have to face
it.
So the consequences if you don't
keep pushing?
Without energy, the source says,
people stay where they are.
Cultural inertia isn't just a
static wall you breakthrough
once.
It's like this constant gentle
pull backwards.
Gravity.
Yeah, always trying to bring
everything back to stillness,
back to the default.
If that initial force, that
burst of energy fades even a
little bit, it's like pushing
something really heavy across a
sticky floor.
The second you ease up.
It slows right down.
That friction, that weight pulls
it back.
It stops, sometimes surprisingly
fast.
The moment of movement takes its
fit off the accelerator.
The cultural system starts
reverting.
And we can see this play out
historically, can't we?
The source uses some really
vivid examples, like the civil
rights movement in the US,
right?
We celebrate, and rightly so,
the huge legal victories, the
Civil Rights Act, the Voting
Rights Act, landmark stuff.
Change the legal landscape
completely.
No more explicit segregation
legally.
Absolutely monumental legal
shifts, no question.
Yeah, but the source asks us to
contrast that with the social
attitudes, the lived realities
on the ground.
Those attitudes, the piece
argues, shifted far more slowly.
Integration, legally mandated,
still meant years of quiet
resistance.
How did that resistance show up
if it wasn't always overt hate?
Well, think about things like
redlining banks, real estate
agents finding ways to keep
neighborhoods segregated through
lending or property rules even
after it was technically
illegal, or how school districts
were redrawn or housing patterns
subtly encouraged that
effectively resegregated schools
without an explicit whites only
sign.
The housing laws changed, yes,
but as the source says,
segregation remained through
other means.
Through cultural habits, social
norms, economic factors.
Exactly the indirect persistent
effects of inertia.
It really highlights that gap
between du jour change the law
on paper and de facto change
what actually happens.
The law moved fast, but the
culture it dragged its feet for
decades.
Then Fast forward a bit.
Occupy Wall Street.
I remember that vividly.
The energy, the camps, the
headlines about the 99%.
Huge global attention felt like
a real moment.
It did felt like maybe something
fundamental was shifting and how
we talked about inequality.
But then almost as quickly as it
popped up it, well, it faded.
It's a textbook example.
According to this framework, a
lack of sustained, consistent
energy allows inertia to just
reassert itself.
Yeah, the initial push was
strong, fueled by anger,
frustration.
But without that ongoing
day-to-day strategic force, it
couldn't maintain momentum
against the sheer weight of the
status quo.
It didn't have the long term
structure to turn outrage into
lasting change.
It was a Sprint when cultural
change is always a marathon.
And even more recently, Black
Lives Matter.
After George Floyd's murder,
there was this incredible surge.
Felt different, didn't it?
Widespread awareness.
Corporations making statements,
Symbols changing.
A genuine sense of potential
turning point for many.
Yeah, but the source points out
even that lost momentum as
attention shifted.
It just reiterates that pattern,
doesn't it?
Even strong movement stall when
energy runs out.
Inertia pulls everything back to
stillness.
It's this constant fundamental
battle for anyone trying to make
deep changes.
The default state is stillness.
The preferred state is familiar
patterns.
It takes this immense continuous
energy just to keep things
moving forward.
And the moment public attention
shifts, the media moves on, the
pressure eases, that cultural
weight starts pulling things
back.
Which brings us to maybe a
really crucial and maybe
uncomfortable point about
resistance itself.
We tend to think pushback
against change comes from
malice, right?
From hate or deep ideological
anger.
That's the common assumption.
But the source suggests
something different.
It says simply, people do not
like to be forced to move.
And that raises a really
important question for all of
us, I think.
When people feel pushed hard by
new laws, new social norms,
public pressure, the source
argues.
They resist not from hate, but
from discomfort.
Discomfort, not hate.
That's the argument.
They dig in when they feel
threatened or when their normal
way of doing things is
challenged.
It's not necessarily about being
a bad person or racist or sexist
or whatever.
It's about a very human, almost
primal instinct to defend what
feels normal.
Because what's familiar feels
safe, New feels uncertain, maybe
risky.
Exactly.
And the source offers this
really critical clarification.
Activists often mistake this for
active hostility.
It is not.
It is human nature to hold safe
still when shoved.
Wow, that's a huge distinction.
It reframes opposition not as an
attack out of malice, but as a
natural reaction to feeling
disrupted, like protecting your
own sense of.
Equilibrium.
Yeah, preserving their mental
and social landscape.
It's self preservation in a way.
So that colleague who might
quietly drag their feet on a new
diversity initiative, or the
neighbor who just shrugs off a
community inclusion effort, they
aren't necessarily acting out of
hate.
Not necessarily.
They might just be deeply
uncomfortable with the change
itself, with anything that feels
like it's messing with their
routine, their understanding of
how things should be, their
worldview.
They're not saying I hate this,
they're maybe saying I'm
comfortable and this feels like
effort I didn't sign up for.
OK, and then there's the other
side of this coin, right?
Apathy.
Yes, the source called apathy,
the other form of inertia.
And it's maybe even more
insidious because it's less
visible than active resistance.
It's quiet in action.
How does that work?
Well, people might agree with
the ideals in theory.
They nod along, maybe sign an
online petition to share a post.
But then they they do nothing to
live them in their actual lives.
Back to old habits.
Exactly.
The moment the spotlight moves
or the pressure's off, they
return to old habits.
They actively avoid the friction
of change.
They're the ones who just sort
of wait for the storm to pass,
hoping the difficult
conversations and the demands
for effort will just go away.
And this widespread apathy, this
quiet drift back to comfort,
that's how progress erodes, even
without anyone actively fighting
it.
Precisely.
It's not that people are
malicious, it's just that the
energy for the change
dissipates.
No one is actively pushing for
it anymore once the initial
surge fades.
It's that constant subtle
gravitational pull back to the
familiar default.
Like trying to keep a boat
pointed upstream in a current if
you stop paddling.
You drift back down.
Exactly.
And societal currents, the pull
of the status quo, are
incredibly strong.
OK, so given all this that the
main opponent might be quiet
resistance, apathy, this deep
seated inertia, not just loud
hate.
How do we actually make lasting
change happen?
Because a lot of modern activism
seems focused on symbols.
Right, that's a key point.
The source addresses.
Removing statues, renaming
buildings, changing language to
be more inclusive.
Things that make a statement.
They absolutely make statements,
they signify evolving values,
reject old norms.
But the source offers a pretty
critical, almost harsh, analysis
here.
These actions make statements
but do not create momentum.
And even more pointedly, it
argues they can even strengthen
inertia by making people
defensive.
How could symbol strengthen
inertia?
That seems counterintuitive.
Well, that inertial majority
perceives a symbolic act not as
progress, but as an attack.
An attack on their history,
their heritage, their identity,
maybe even their family's
stories.
If it makes them feel like their
world is being torn down without
their input or consent, they
might dig in harder.
Not necessarily out of hate for
the new symbol, but out of a
perceived threat to their own
sense of self and stability.
So they resist the change even
more because of how it was
presented.
Potentially, yes.
They are suddenly going to
embrace the new ideal if they
feel personally attacked or
invalidated by the process.
That digging in creates more
resistance, reinforcing the
inertia.
That's a really crucial
critique.
It suggests symbols matter, but
they can't be the whole game.
Right, the source is blunt.
Real change requires more than
symbolic victories.
You need something that gets at
the root cause that inertia
itself, not just the surface
manifestations.
So what does work then?
If symbols aren't enough?
What does real change require
according to this perspective?
Connecting back to the core
idea, real, lasting change needs
steady, lasting force.
Consistency over drama.
The marathon, not the Sprint.
Exactly.
Think less like explosions, more
like water slowly shaping stone
over time.
And crucially, it needs stories
and policies that invite people
to move rather than ordering
them to.
Invite, not order.
That sounds different.
It highlights a proactive,
persuasive approach, not a
coercive 1.
Instead of just telling people
they're wrong, or shaming them
or forcing compliance, it's
about making the new way feel
appealing, beneficial, natural,
maybe even easier in the long
run than the old way.
Building bridges for that
majority to cross instead of
just yelling at them from the
other side.
That's a good way to think about
it.
Yeah, and we've seen the
opposite happen too, haven't we?
Where progress doesn't just slow
down, it actually seems to roll
back, sometimes quietly, until
you suddenly realize ground has
been lost.
The source points to some really
concerning contemporary
examples.
Things still very much in the
news, the rollback of
affirmative action, weakening of
voting protections and re
segregation of schools.
These are major shifts
backwards.
Huge, and the critical point the
source makes is why these
happened.
It argues they were not driven
by loud hate.
It wasn't primarily extremist
groups achieving these policy
changes through sheer force.
So what drove it then?
According to this analysis, they
happened because energy faded
and inertia reasserted itself.
The sustained push for those
protections and policies
weakened overtime.
The constant effort wasn't
maintained.
Right.
And a quiet, persistent pull of
the old ways, the established
systems, the comfortable
defaults.
It just gradually reasserted
control, the collective sigh of
relief when the pressure eased.
Allow these reversals to happen,
often through complex legal or
procedural means, not
necessarily overt declarations.
So the message is stark.
Without that constant effort,
society just slides back.
Back to what's familiar,
comfortable.
Easy.
People naturally return to easy
patterns and that final line
from the source.
We keep coming back to the
weight of culture hold.
It's always there, always
pulling back to stillness, to
the default.
It's not a force you defeat
once.
It's something you have to
perpetually manage, counteract.
Which brings us right back to
the core challenge for anyone
trying to make real change.
The source says movements must
accept this truth.
Its biggest opponent is not the
extremist, but the mass that
resists motion.
And that resistance, as we've
discussed, is typically quiet
and stubborn and fundamentally,
crucially, not born of anger but
of human nature.
It's just how we are
collectively understanding that
changes the whole game plan,
doesn't it?
It really does.
So if the biggest hurdle isn't
shouting enemies, but this quiet
preference for staying put, this
inherent resistance to being
moved, how do we overcome it?
What is the path forward for
making change that actually
sticks?
Well, the source lays out a
method.
It's clear, but it's definitely
not easy.
Movements must apply steady
force.
Steady force, consistent
pressure, yes.
Not one big shove.
Not just flashy campaigns.
Continuous, consistent pressure
like a slow geological process.
And they must strive to make
change feel like evolution, not
disruption.
Evolution, not disruption.
How do you do that?
It means integrating new ideas,
new practices, in ways that feel
more more organic, less
threatening to that inertial
majority, building those
pathways we talked about, making
the new way seem like a natural
progression, maybe even easier
or more beneficial eventually.
So it becomes less scary.
Less scary, more appealing.
The ultimate goal, and this is
absolutely key, is to turn
ideals into habits that last.
Habits.
But once something becomes a
habit, once it feels normal,
automatic, effortless, just the
way things are done, then it
becomes part of the culture's
inertia itself, but now working
in the new desired direction.
So you're essentially rewiring
the cultural default setting.
Exactly.
Not just applying patches, but
changing the underlying
operating system over time.
And the source is clear, this is
hard work.
Yeah, it concludes.
This is harder than fighting
hate.
It's not as dramatic, doesn't
grab headlines the same way.
It is the slow, patient work of
applying enough energy for long
enough to shift the weight of a
culture that prefers to stay
where it is.
It's that marathon again.
Sustained, thoughtful effort,
not just emotional reaction.
It requires incredible
persistence, empathy and a
really deep understanding of
human nature and social
dynamics.
It means recognizing the real
battle isn't always against the
visible enemy shouting insults,
but often against those
invisible currents of
familiarity and comfort that
keep pulling us back to where
we've always been.
That's the essence of overcoming
cultural inertia.
Cultural inertia.
It doesn't shout, it doesn't
March, but it holds everything
in place with this immense quiet
power.
Understanding this force, this
silent opponent, seems
absolutely critical for anyone
who cares about making genuine,
lasting progress in any field,
really.
Racial justice, climate change,
even just changing how your team
works at the office.
Yeah, if we keep misidentifying
the main source of resistance,
focusing only on the loud stuff,
we're just going to keep getting
frustrated when things don't
fundamentally change around.
Seems likely, yes.
So OK, let's bring this home.
What does this all mean for you,
listening right now as you go
about your day?
Maybe you're thinking about
movements you support,
initiatives at work, or even
just changes you'd like to see
in your own community, your
family.
Consider where things might feel
stalled.
Is it really because of loud,
active, hateful opposition
blocking the path?
Or could it be at least partly
this subtle, persistent force of
cultural inertia, that quiet
majority, maybe even including
parts of ourselves, sometimes
just preferring to hold still?
It's a different lens to look
through.
It really is.
So think about it.
What might steady force look
like in those specific
situations?
What kind of invitation to
change, not an order could
genuinely help turn those ideals
into lasting habits?
How could you make the new path
feel less like a scary
disruption and more like a
natural, maybe even easier,
evolution?
It's a different way of thinking
about progress, and maybe, just
maybe, it holds a key to
unlocking real, enduring change.